-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I am here with Amy Poehler,
and we're about to play
a round of Instant Spoilers.
-♪ Instant spoilers,
instant spoilers ♪
-This is a really fun game.
We played it with Tom Holland.
-Oh, I love Tom Holland.
He's the best.
-I know, me, too.
He is the best. I love him.
Now, Amy, we each have
a stack of cards
with movie titles on them.
When it's your turn,
you have to draw a card,
and you have to
shout out a spoiler
for that movie.
And the other person
tries to guess the movie,
based only on the spoiler.
Sound good?
-Let's do it.
-Alright, Amy,
you'll be guessing first,
and have to guess
as many as possible
before time runs out.
Ready, on the clock, and go.
Uh, Bruce Willis was dead
the whole time.
-Uh, "Die hard."
[ Buzzer ]
-Uh, no, "Sixth Sense."
Sorry.
"Die hard"?
-Well, "Die Hard" has "die"
in the title, so...
okay, let's keep going.
-Here we go.
The boat sinks at the end.
-Oh, um, "Gilligan's Island."
[ Buzzer ]
-No.
-Are you sure?
-That's a TV show.
-Alright.
-Next, here we go.
-Potayto, potahto.
Here we go.
-Uh, uh, they -- they find Nemo.
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, "The Little Mermaid."
[ Buzzer ]
-No.
I said it, actually.
-No, wait, "The Big Mermaid."
[ Buzzer ]
-No, they find Nemo.
-Oh, okay,
"The Big Mermaid 2."
[ Buzzer ]
-Aw, man.
Amy, you got a total of
zero answers correct.
-Hmm.
-Um...
You know, you've seen movies
before.
You know what movies are, right?
-Yeah, I thought that buzzer
sound meant that I got it.
It means I didn't get it?
-No, I guess not.
-Okay.
Well, to be fair, Jimmy,
your spoilers could use
a little bit of work.
-Yeah, well, I don't know.
When Tom and I played,
he got like 5 points.
-Yeah, well, I'm sorry
I'm not [Bleep] Tom Holland.
Okay?
-Alright, let me show you
how it's done here.
Let's get that clock
back up on the screen.
Amy, whenever you are ready,
come on.
-Here we go.
-Yeah.
-Okay, Iron Man snaps
and kills Thanos.
-"Notting Hill."
[ Buzzer ]
"Peter's Friends."
-No.
-"Four Weddings and a Funeral"?
[ Buzzer ]
I don't know, pass.
-Oh, okay, alright.
Okay, you're gonna get this one.
Gwyneth Paltrow's head
is in the box.
-"Sex and the City 2."
[ Buzzer ]
-No, but I thought that, too.
I did think it was that.
-Yeah.
It's not that?
-Okay. No.
Okay, here's a good spoiler.
The killer is
Jason Voorhees' mother.
-"Ernest Goes to Camp."
[ Buzzer ]
-No.
No, different camp movie.
-"Meatballs"!
[ Buzzer ]
-Mnh-mnh.
Different camp movie.
-"Camp Nowhere."
[ Buzzer ]
-No. Different camp movie.
-"Heavyweights."
[ Buzzer ]
-No. Different camp movie.
-"Wet Hot American Summer."
[ Buzzer ]
-I don't know.
I've never heard of it.
[ Buzzer ]
-Hey, is it just me,
or is the buzzer getting
louder and, like, meaner?
-It is, it is.
The buzzer is aggressive.
But, honestly,
it does make sense,
because you did do
even worse than I did.
-I don't know
what's going on over here.
By now, Tom Holland and I
had, like --
-You know what, Jimmy?
Why don't you marry Tom Holland?
Why don't you go and marry him
if you love him so much.
-He lives in England.
-Okay.
-Um...we have one round left.
Let's see how many
we can get this, together.
This is a partnership.
Here we go.
All we have to do
is get one answer right.
Just one, and I will be happy.
-Okay, me too.
-Yeah, that's all I want
is us to be happy.
Are you ready for this?
-Yeah.
-Here we go.
-I'm ready.
-Okay. Oh, gosh. Oh...
well, it has, like, a beginning
and then a middle...
-Uh, "Tree of Life."
Terrence Malick's
"Tree of Life."
[ Bell dings ]
-Yes! Yes!
That's it!
We did it! We did it!
[ Both laugh ]
-Suck it, Tom Holland!
-Coming for you, Spider-Man!
-Oh, yeah!
Well, we're gonna be right back
with more "Tonight Show,"
everybody.
come on back.
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪